today's topic i think it is absolutely
ridiculous that we allow 18 year olds to
take huge student loans to go to
university
i know you weren't expecting all that
right that was a pretty long topic
i'm mad at it there's something i've
been thinking about for a long time i
remember writing about this like six
years ago why
um i'm 30 now and a lot of my university
a lot of my friends from high school
went to university they're still paying
off their debts struggling with it
absolutely
and the worst part is most of them don't
work in any fields related to the major
that they do that is correct
now a lot of you at home sorry we're
going to say should have chosen a better
major and
and i think we all agree you know a lot
of people picked stupid majors
whatever but you're 18
[Music]
in a lot of places you're not even legal
enough to drink because they're like
you can't handle the toxic effects but
you're sensible enough to make a
decision to take on 50 000
worth of debt that's like a down payment
for a really nice house in a lot of
places
like i'm confused my dog paid me for my
car
was not that much
[Music]
you know
[Laughter]
hold up hold up park those hands and
just talk to me calmly for
a condom it's not that much
and it's it's frightening because it's
not even just a thing of like people
making wrong choices they're too young
it's also like
societal pressure the pressure you have
coming out of high school to go
to university and to pick something and
to do it is
wild yes everyone's pushing you your
your guidance counselors are pushing you
um your parents are pushing you your
friends in society are telling you
that's the next logical step so a lot of
people just go through with it
thinking all right and most of them are
like i don't know what i'm gonna do so
i'm gonna
i'm gonna choose psychology because i
like how people think or whatever and
then they all drop out right i saw some
crazy numbers man let me see if i could
pull this up
ready for this 70 of finance majors
regret their choice
of course 71 of physics
majors wish they could go back in time
71 percent of social worker majors said
they regretted their area of studies
uh and the sources are pay
scalendron.com i'll put a link in the
description below so you can see
that was the case for a lot of the
people that i knew around me you know
and and one-third of university students
end up switching majors at some point
now again i'll bet that's not always
linked to you being regretting your
choice or whatever but
and this is how not only does high
school fail you
yeah but it also is complicit in this
and the crazy thing is that schools are
incentivized
by how many students they send off to
university so it's in their best
interest not to teach you skills to be
an
independent adult because they just want
to funnel you down there my guidance
counselor pushed me towards that even
though i didn't want to go yeah
i remember going to orientation day and
i just sat in class and i fell asleep
and i was like [ __ ] if i'm
falling asleep on orientation i was
knocked out
i'm like i can't make it so i said i'm
not doing it and i remember everyone
looking at me like i was crazy and i was
like y'all do your thing i'll do my
thing it is what it is
but that's how school is complicit and
failing
and then there's the government yeah i
mean the government made student loans
on you can't file bankruptcy and get rid
of them it's like
one of the few loans in life where
there's no way to get out of it it's
going to follow you forever
so they have given this
loan right they'll forgive debts of
bankers don't forget
the debts of a whole bunch of people
when they file bankruptcy but to an 18
year old
who does this just coming out of his
mom's basement apparently
that loan cannot be forgotten they
forgave people that fraud in the
government but they're not going to
forgive
you know what i mean bro people that
sold a whole bunch of money in the
government
they forgave them but not 18 year olds
that don't know what to do with life
like these people knew exactly what the
hell that was doing
yeah it really is a shameful system
that's in place
and i think people have been so used to
it for so long just like you can just
embrace it but
it's not because we've had it for so
long that it's a good thing and for
certainly how i'm going to raise my
children there's no way
i want to just funnel them through the
university pay for their education
or encourage them to go unless they
really know what they want to do and if
they don't there's nothing wrong with
waiting
we tell young people they have to have
their together and they have to know
where they want to go
bro i didn't know what i wanted to do
until i was 25 and most people don't
most people if they think they do or
they're pretending they end up realizing
later on that they're in a dead-end job
that they never want to do but because
it's linked to their major and then what
happens
what happens then you get burnout then
after that you get all that you don't
it's a [ __ ] cycle it's a cycle it's
sad
you get burnout you get all of this
depression and everything and stuff
because of one thing that was pressured
to you and you think it's normal because
it's
just all around you and it's just normal
everything
and everyone is being pressured you're
being pressured but then again it
happens
boom this happens and you just feel bad
about yourself but that's that's what it
is
they groom you into thinking that
there's no point
of learning everything that i learned
learning all the things that i learned
in math if i'm not going to become a
mathematician or i'm not going to work
from that somewhere
and you should go in that field and
experiment
that when you get there when you get to
that field you understand what i'm
saying
high school does not prepare you for
adulthood or outside
anything outside of passing exams for
university none of the skill sets or
most of the skill sets i learned in high
school
were not applicable to my adult life
once i left school
i know so they pretty much are just
funneling me down a thing where i can
pass your university exam where you can
pay
they're grooming you to be able to pay
later on
but not grooming you for life so i'm
gonna be able to know what pythagoras is
and what past tense for 3.1413 whatever
why do i notice but i had to learn how
to balance my attacks
thank god my mom was working in finance
i had to like my mom took my hand and be
like okay we going to do your taxes and
i'm like don't
don't are you the one that's going to do
your tax no you need to learn that
but i was privileged that having a mom
that took my hand and worked in that
field
but they groom you to go to see jab i'm
sorry
to go to go to college to go to
university to pay up but not
groom you for life yep you can't balance
your taxes
you don't know law i remember i had to
go my fifth grade of high school and i
had to choose a class
a complimentary class and i was starting
to look like a man
and getting put over by the pull over by
the police so i took a law
class and after i got out of that law
class i realized
everybody should take that class this
shouldn't be something that you pick and
choose
you should know about law you should
know about money you should know about
credit
you should know about food you should
know about all that but no
no how to calculate one side of a
triangle
not never have i used that [ __ ] yeah
you know there's a lot of questions to
ask why don't we learn how to drive why
don't we know how to cook
why don't we learn how to balance
budgets so many uh essential skills as
adults that people don't learn to later
talk onto life until
there's already been ramifications for
not knowing that like to me it's such a
sad state
still that's a lot of people just
constantly switching or feeling or
dropping out all together you didn't
have any pressure when growing up
you didn't oh i did but you know how i
am right how stubborn
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah of course yeah
you didn't give them yeah my mom got
excited she saw i had good grades
i had some university acceptances and i
said mom
you want me to go to university how
about i drop out of high school
so you can imagine the disgust
on her face you're a piece of [ __ ] i
like it oh yeah
i remember i remember my parents my
parents weren't saying because
everything was about academics
my parents told me my sister they told
me the first person who'll be
who becomes a doctor we're gonna pay my
cadillac right and i'm like
this is not fair right this is three
years old
three years and a half older than me
what and on top of that like i already
failed classes i
i got left back my sister jumped one and
i'm like
oh wow oh oh
we gonna do me like that so and even
then elementary school they were always
like the last years of elementary school
like this is your most important years
because it's gonna decide
where you're gonna how you're gonna be
in in high school i get to high school
these are the most important years
because it's going to determine
everything you're going to go in college
i get to college
nobody gives a [ __ ] nobody no
no no teacher really gives a you're left
alone
and you don't know what you're going to
become for the rest of your life
yep the thing is i'm not i'm not trying
to downplay the importance of higher
education like
obviously i want a doctor who's gone
through his rigorous training
and went through university and did all
that like i don't want some doctor from
the academy of bro science
right like i want somebody who went to
mcgill's dude listen dude
listen now what's going on yes that you
know you kind of have an infection
exactly so we're gonna like sort of cut
your spleen right
right all right so we're gonna go ahead
and cut you open because you know we're
gonna slice you up i don't want no
i don't want no dog to be like all right
bro we're gonna slice you up
remove that bag it if you want we get to
you
you know what i mean take a little
picture with it
so you back in and then you're good to
go cool hey hey [ __ ] is your [ __ ]
falling out
pick it up with a garbage bag let's go
we need a doctor like
i don't i don't want to deny that but
all i'm trying to say is this i think
there can be
a middle ground jubilee
i think take all your [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out
this was a perfectly perfectly fine
video no i'm saying
take all your [ __ ] and get the [ __ ] out
it was a perfectly fine video
you had to bring jubilee in this what
are you saying that not just because i
said jubilee you want to cut me
wow no that's corny that's corn that's
yeah i really do think it could be a
middle ground in that regards and i
think you can find a
a happy space between you know
understand that
higher education is something that
people should seriously consider and
also
not handing out student loans like it's
cotton candy
at the state fair feel me there you go
all right it shouldn't be that easy for
me to access without me knowing the
ramifications that
if you maybe have taught me about what
debt looks like what an unforgivable
loan looks like
then maybe i would understand when i
make that choice but you don't do
that and that's the problem i have with
the approach
it almost feels like a bait and switch
and so schools play a part in this our
government plays a part in this
society does by overvaluing education
all the time in
higher education and not putting enough
emphasis on important life skills that
they just expect us to learn on our own
randomly
which most people don't most people
don't know how to make a budget
no most people don't know what how
important it is to manage your credit
until you've already [ __ ] it up a
little bit so
find that middle ground find that middle
ground because we're sacrificing a lot
of a potential talent and youth
and that's the sad part so i see people
struggling with their student debt and i
think it's sad
people are leaving running away from
their countries and it's just like
i remember one day even when they're
like well you could do a trade job but
they were really like
yeah you could go and trade but whatever
and you could if it's your thing it's
your thing
but there was a kind of a shame around
trade jobs
and trade school where it's like uh you
could but whatever
go to college and university that's a
bad better choice in life and like no
no that's not like that i know some
successful
people that are doing successful yeah so
yeah success is not necessarily being a
doctor i mean good for you if you are
that's great it's
totally great but it's not necessarily
that and
yeah it is what it is and guys you know
if you're listening to this and you
haven't made that decision yet or
whether you want to go or not like
take your time don't let anybody rush i
don't care what your parents say i don't
care what society says i know it's tough
to
try to say no to all that but i
understand it's ultimately your life
you're the one who's gonna have to pay
that debt you're the one who's gonna
have to struggle with that
it's not right and even though the wide
world
is not there to give you a path to walk
on figure out how to get experience and
what you want to do
there are options out there there are
ways to get it done
so um one thing i always like to do is i
like to bet on myself
i'll figure it out i'm going to try
things yeah and if i fail along the way
that's fine but at least i did it my way
so um i recommend that for most folks
and um
if that's something that you consider i
encourage it and if you're struggling
with student debts i feel your pain well
not literally because i'm not in debt
but um
i feel for you it's wrong it's really
wrong a lot of folks were done dirty
i think the only thing we can do is try
to teach our kids differently yeah
pretty much
that's all the the system's not going to
change then we have to change the way we
operate with our families
so why don't you guys leave your
comments below we want to hear about
mistakes you made with the
major that you picked and whether or not
you regret it man the amount of people i
know right now
who are in the middle of a major and
don't want to finish it but they're
already two years ago
they already they paid so much it's not
so much because they want to finish it
you you gave so much you already like
the death is not going to go away
and having that debt you know you're two
years in you have one year left
uh you're in the middle of the year you
want to give up but i mean you gain
if you give up right now at least well
there's not at least you give up right
now you still got a debt but you don't
have a diploma
so if you force yourself to at least
have a diploma and have a debt that has
man it's crazy
it's just crazy out here it's crazy man
they groom you
to pay later that's what it is they they
groom you to milk you that's cray
z and they're 18 bro yup sad
hey but that's it for today's uh video
if uh you guys have any ideas
leave them in the comments below
[Music]
foreign